kim's convenience aired its final
episode last night after its abrupt
cancellation a few weeks ago
so when the actors shot the episode they
just shot they just thought
they were shooting their season five
finale no idea was actually the final
episode ever
uh yeah simulu has been very vocal about
his bitterness over the cancellation
before the episode aired last night he
tweeted this
on the eve of what is now to be the
series finale of
kim's convenience i hoped i'd be at a
point where i could speak about it
with a clear head but the truth is i'm
still pretty
angry hours of therapy are sure to
follow you all deserved a proper
ending i have thoughts about our quote
cancellation
and they come with t and receipts for
now
they will remain in my head
yeah so paul hung lee live streamed his
thoughts after the episode aired last
night and simu joined him so first
here's the final scene
from what is now the kim's convenience
series finale
time to say goodbye oh take us something
from a store okay
i have to hurry up
lunch buddies always
where are you going meeting up with
friends i won't be late bye everyone bye
bye
thank you
i'll drive you safe everybody
dino was just so good robo and uh no one
had a fight
with the show ending the way it did
everybody wants answers everybody wants
to know why why why and i get it i
totally get it's understandable
um and that's in time perspective
time give everything a chance to sort of
cool off a bit and like calmer heads
prevail
and then you know the truth will come
out and
my my biggest wish always is that
something positive comes from it that we
learn from this without
blame without finger pointing i think it
was a great
season finale and i'll say that again
i believe for me others a great season
finale
as a series finale
to be honest my first impression was i
felt a little empty at the end
you know it was a nice visual image of
apa and oma walking away
into the shadows sort of front lit and
you could just see their silhouettes but
i kind of thought that's it that's it
i'm still angry
for sure for a lot of reasons and and i
know i don't want to burden
you guys with the you know with all of
that paul and i will do that
commiserating on our own time
but um you know that that being said i
think it does
bring me a little bit of joy quite a bit
of joy actually knowing that
knowing that you know the finale has
touched everyone
you're right in the sense that there's
no immediate cliffhanger
if you guys watching are are kind of
i don't know about confused but you know
i'm sensing a lot of really positive
vibes and if you're
if you're like oh these two commercially
old men are still talking about
about you know the cancellation like
they're still bitter or they can't let
something go
i mean just know that without you know
again like
trying to throw anybody on the bus or
cause too much of a ruckus it's like
we i mean there there's just been the
things that have
you know we have fought for over the
years and and
things that we strive for with the show
ambitions hopes and
and all of that so we carried a lot of
that very very close to our chest
you know we we cared so deeply about the
show and a big part of that is seeing
the way that it was received by you guys
yeah so samantha says i'm really really
going to miss the show i love them
that's just i just got into it on
netflix now it's over
and he says kim's convenience is an
iconic show that will go down in history
and is original in
concept rendox as well that was savage
talk about an inconvenience
uh paul says scene was about to go off
spill the tea um that's the weird thing
about this so i watched this live stream
i'll admit i'm not a viewer
of kim's convenience but i don't think
i've ever seen an ending of a show where
the actors are this vocal of how pissed
off they are
that it's over and they're really
hinting at there's something that
something went on behind the scenes
the story was the creators wanted to
leave to do another show obviously
there's something more to that jeff yeah
what's your reaction to
this really abrupt at a time like this
where people are trying to celebrate
asian culture and
this iconic show is gone
yeah i'm you know i fully admit i i've
heard faint things about it but i've
really got in but just from a show
perspective this is the reason why
fans are hesitant about investing in
shows
because you invest you put in your time
you connect with these characters
you care about the storylines and then
after two seasons
or x amount of seasons they're gone and
that's what that's what the reality is
in this streaming era
you get in you do your three seasons and
then you get out or
it's the curse of success one of your
favorite actors
blows up because of the show and now
they're booked and busy
right and and you you they can't come
back to do the shelter they have to be
written off
or the show has to end um i read that
the creators wanted to do another show
so it's like for me
it's i'm kind of torn because if they
created the show and that's their show
and they wanted to end it at that point
yeah i if you're an actor i would be
pissed because
you didn't get a chance to finish what
you started or end on a proper note
but you were acting in the show it
wasn't really your idea your creation
and the person who who made it
wants to end it there now if there were
any pressures or anything beyond the
scenes
that forced those creators out then you
know that's a thing that the to talk
about but
i think that we we don't have as much
information to go on as of yet
so i'm hesitant to to lean you the way i
will say
i can think of a lot of shows that i
wish would have got
a better ending and just some type of a
satisfac
satisfactory ending for us as viewers
so that you know our investment can be
paid off
um so i i i can i can definitely feel
those actors who put in years in
time and now it's kind of like we didn't
get to go out the way that we wanted to
go out
yeah it was very confusing for fans
normally the the normal reaction is your
favorite show gets cancelled
and fans immediately start a save kim's
convenience campaign because it's
normally
the network that pulls the show where
the people who buy the show decide to
not
to not renew but this wasn't that case
there was no saving this show because
it was the people who created the show
were the ones that walked away this
wasn't the this wasn't the network
and both um simu and paul have said that
this was definitely not about money
neither of them walked in there saying
hey you know we want more for this
and the other confusing thing is that
the creators of this show
would choose to not capitalize on the
fact that two of their stars
paul is now a nerd god because he's one
of the stars of mandalorian
and in a couple of months simulu is
going to be a marvel
superhero so you have both of those
people in your cast
you don't have to pay them a dollar more
and you walk away from that show
like none of it makes sense
yeah linda says what a strange situation
and yeah that's the thing in my live
stream
both paul and simu hint at like
something is going to be revealed at
some point that we know
the whole story their thing like jeff i
i've watched the show but watching that
last scene
like i know fans are saying like story
lines weren't wrapped up but that last
scene
strikes me as a finale seriously
episode people saying goodbye take
something from the store that final shot
of them walking off
so if i was an actor shooting that scene
and i just think this is a season finale
doing that scene i'd be like this seems
like
a serious finale ending scene right here
that we're doing even though apparently
there's storylines that we're still
hanging
that actual scene very much seems like a
final scene of a series
that's what strikes me as that's like
the part in punkt
where you start to realize something may
be going on in there you might get you
might be getting pranked
and if you just keep on going with it
you're like ah i knew yeah
for me seeing that clip i was like wait
that was the season finale
that looks like that actually looks like
if you if you watch
a lot of of tv right and serialized tv
you can tell when when shows
shoot things as if shoot finales as if
they may
not get another season
so they put it in a place where certain
stories
are wrapped up but there's still
cliffhangers
and loose threads that could be built on
for the next season if there is a next
season but they always leave you in a
what if place where
you're content enough that it stopped
here
but if it ever comes back you can build
upon
it maybe me me not knowing that the show
or the story lines or everything
when i watched that clip i i felt at
peace
and i don't need to watch it so if like
you said graham if i was on that set
and i watched and they said that's a
wrap i would have kind of said wow
this feels like it's it but it's not
right
so maybe the creator it had already been
renewed
it had already been renewed
the thing it seems like she's not seen
yeah they would have like they weren't
waiting on anything the show was renewed
like for another season when they shot
that they knew there was going to be
another season
yeah but that's weird are we
this scene seems very has a real
finality to it yeah like yeah that'd be
very strange yeah when you turn that
when you turn the lights out
when like when friends or wherever it is
when you when you turn the lights out in
the place where the show takes place
and it's the fight it's the last season
it's the last episode of the season
that's the end it's the lights out is
the end
watching off everyone says goodbye take
something from the store
like this is just closed like yeah
is sliding across the floor they bring
they bring in the next people's
furniture the next resident's virtual
you'd be like
what what's this yeah like if i want to
stop that like he turns it off and then
he walks off the only cliffhanger i have
is whether carlton ever stops sliding on
the floor
but uh but you're content so again like
that
those those emotional beats and those
production
cues and everything that you see it
feels pretty final so
i don't know if somebody knew something
that we didn't but
yeah it all it all is pretty weird and
when you have people who are
starring in other series and starring in
movies
and are elevating their their profile
thus
elevating your show yeah you're messing
the church's money up when you cancel
like that i'm sorry
that that whatever whatever that new
thing they're doing
i it better be worth it